pour les conditions qu est-ce qu m merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse aux milices affaires
étrangères ou au premier ministre elle
concernait le train direct elle concerne
l'attitude de la france à l'unesco
depuis quelques mois lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'état d'israël il y a quelques mois
monsieur le premier ministre vous même
vous nous aviez assuré que le vote
précédent sur israël qui remettait en
cause un certain nombre d'installations
juive à jérusalem que ce vote de la
france favorable sous la pression des
émirats arabes et bien que ce vote
allait être réfléchie et sanctionnés et
que la france s'engagerait plus dans
cette direction
or que s'est il passé il sait pas c'est
qu'il y a quelques jours et bien une
résolution très voisines précédent qui
concerne le mont du temple le mont du
temple a été adoptée par l'unesco sur un
texte proposé par les pays musulmans
qu'a fait la france elle s'est abstenue
elle est absolument que toutes les
démocraties occidentales sans exception
à l'exception de l'espagne les
etats-unis la grande-bretagne
l'allemagne n'ont pas ne voulait pas
laisser passer ce texte et vous l'avez
laissée passer
monsieur le premier ministre il faudrait
savoir en définitive ce que cherche la
france à l'égard de l'état d'israël
est ce que vous croyez sincèrement que
le fait de considérer comme
palestinienne mont du temple va changer
l'affectation historique du mont du
temple à la culture juive et à la
culture chrétienne voire à la
civilisation internationale c'est une
plaisanterie
est ce que vous croyez monsieur le
premier ministre que l'unesco va sortir
grandi de cette opération de tambouille
politicienne fait avec des émirs est ce
que vous croyez qu'il est digne pour la
france de soutenir une résolution de cet
ordre qui et dénaturent complètement le
sens de la défense de la culture
désormais l'unesco c'est la contre
culture et la france se déshonore la
france en a assez de lécher la babouche
des émirs
la parole est un monsieur harlem désir
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît allez
franchement merci monsieur le genre de
réaction n'est pas nécessaire mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député claude goasguen
je vous réponds pour le ministre les a
fait rage terre qui est actuellement
retenu par des obligations la france est
l'amie d'israël et la france cherchent
la paix au proche orient
permettez moi d'abord un rappel des
faits le conseil exécutif de l'unesco a
examiné un projet de résolution sur la
vieille ville de jérusalem à l'issue des
échanges avec nos partenaires certaines
formules qui avait fait polémique et qui
avait amené précédemment à ce que nous
contestions ce texte ont été retirés et
ce texte a repris des éléments que nous
soutenons la nécessité de protéger le
patrimoine l'importance de la vieille
ville de jérusalem pour les trois
religions monothéistes la suppression de
la mention de soi disant fausses tombes
juives ce qui était inacceptable
néanmoins la mention de termes
déséquilibré a conduit une majorité de
pays européens à s'abstenir la france a
aussi fait le choix de l'abstention
tout comme l'espagne la suède par
exemple notre position traditionnelle
celle de la france quant à jérusalem et
quant au conflit israélo palestinien
elle est immuable pour la france la
priorité c'est la paix c'est la solution
à deux états c'est la reconnaissance
mutuelle entre israéliens et
palestiniens
et concernant jérusalem c'est le
maintien du statu quo de la ville de
jérusalem ville fondamental pour les
trois grandes religions monothéistes
juifs chrétiens et musulmans doivent s'y
voir leurs lieux saints respecter notre
position c'est aussi monsieur goasguen
que nous condamnons la colonisation sous
toutes ses formes
non seulement parce qu'elle est
contraire au droit international mais
aussi parce qu'elle constitue elle
constitue le principal obstacle à la
paix quand la colonisation progresse la
solution de deux états s'éloigne au delà
de cette polémique l'objectif essentiel
que nous poursuivons tu ne veux pas
perdre de vue c'est la relance de la
mobilisation internationale autour du
conflit israélo palestinien la reprise
d'un dialogue entre les deux parties
la recherche d'une solution à deux états
israël et la palestine vivant côte à
côte dans la paix et la sécurité
c'est la seule viable pour parvenir à un
règlement les jeunes ministres
la parole est